there are so many ingredients it's
probably gonna take a long time find a
zero-waste
these are super complicated recipes I'm
worried the zero waste version is gonna
be so much more money the Rosi Rosi zero
my daddy makes the stew chicken nations
we have our own special chicken dish so
I'm really excited to make stew chicken
my homegirl danny is also going to be
making a Caribbean dish she's Puerto
Rican and I'm very excited because she's
making mofongo and I've never had it I
met Joyce through art who's been my best
friend since we are nine I'm really
excited to bond with grace and make
Caribbean food I'm gonna be in so good
and you guys are gonna get to watch me
ain't good
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm gonna see if they're gonna let me
put the chitchat run in this bag or if
they gonna be weird about it this is
like anybody Rico they just have it out
here later just one big one maybe
yes
thank you so much both of my mom and dad
were born and raised in Haiti
I am half off reporter Egan and half
Irish for those of you who are liquid so
for Puerto Rican it's basically my mom
is black but speaks Spanish my dad's
really secretive with his recipes so he
sent me a link of a website he really
likes and he said just go with that
chicken cuz you ain't gettin mine this
is all things are normally buy and this
is the cost you know it seems pretty
mama pretty average for what I would
normally pay to get this a lot of things
are already packaged free like the herbs
and the onions a really good offer is
getting beans and rice and cloth bags
getting produce without plastic and then
trying to find these seasonings about so
my recipe is just from experience and
knowing what I like I also like don't
want any shade from other Puerto Ricans
how I make my phone glows how I make my
mouth full well if you don't like it you
can make your own mobile phone so I
guess what I would normally get what do
you think your challenges are going to
be getting the
son in the adobo and like maybe
we're gonna put everything back that's
packaged and then go to
but we are gonna buy the party that
wasn't packaged and still never see the
dishes so good I would never drink
chicken broth but I would drink the
chicken broth from this chicken that's
how good this chicken is mofongo is a
staple dish in the Puerto Rican culture
they do it all over the Caribbean it's
sort of crispy and gooey
my favorite filling in particular is an
uncle stop can I get three lobsters in
this food is definitely a big place in
my heart and my soul it's what I was
raised on it's one of the ways I connect
to my culture my background in Puerto
Rican cooking is lots of fried delicious
food which is the majority of most
Puerto Rican food and adobo they
actually pop it over with glass and a
metal top so it's like at least fully
recyclable get the bullion in glass this
is definitely interesting
so I got my beans and rice I'm gonna
take a picture of the food number
Haitians have a traditional mayonnaise
called
amaz Epis I'm not really sure I don't
know Creoles because my parents wanted
me to assimilate to American society so
if you guys want another tea that's why
I made that my dad always made them for
cooking any of these dishes I thought it
was a brand Moho because it had the
labeling on it but he made the sauce
himself and just used the container so
my dad is truly doing any big dish is
usually overnight we're gonna put the
celery stock some red peppers for the
haters in the back lemon lime and sour
orange juice vinegar addresses destroy
garlic ground cloves 5 sprigs of thyme a
couple sprigs of cilantro enough how to
make my eggs call me back
habaneros I grew up knowing this is
called scotch bonnet chicken bullion
this is not what normal Haitians were to
use when you should use a Goya cubed um
it's in Spanish it's really thick like
me a little bit of adobo I let the sauce
sit overnight so the flavors can really
come out all right so I'm making my
sofrito we're gonna start with the onion
then we're gonna do garlic it's really
hard for me to find sweet peppers that
weren't in bags so I got the bigger
sweet peppers we'll do 1 green pepper
and 2 mixed colored peppers oil wine and
then I'm just gonna blend
tomatoes to pluck these babies in there
we couldn't find culantro because it's
LA and it's just really hard to find but
if you can't find culantro just mix a
little bit of oregano with the cilantro
and it tastes about the same and last
but not least our half a lime juice and
our couple tablespoons of salt let's get
a nice green and then we have our
sofrito
I'm peeling the plantains you kind of
just like chop off the ends of an angle
like this and then you find a place
where you would like to peel from so I
usually like to go from the back stick
your thumb in and then it usually peels
right off feel like Vanna White is also
Puerto Rican oh right so I am mixing
lemon lime and orange juice to rinse the
chicken off and clean it with it's just
a big tradition that fresh citrus
aftertaste that you get when a Mayan
village again it's so important so next
I'm gonna put the chicken in the
marinade after the flesh ripped out I
saw these beans overnight and I cook
sound be pureed like before US isn't but
mixed we put the coconut now the chicken
bullion 1 tablespoon of olive oil it's
gonna check on the rice
I look looking good so I'm something and
then we're gonna stir it see that gooey
thickness that is the key to this spot
oh my god I love this wah it's so nice I
love the coconut flavor and thank you
guys for making me a little vegetarian
plate yeah
I'm gonna start the chicken word I've
been letting the chicken marinate for
about four hours and it's looking pretty
seasoned to me but I'm gonna add a
little bit more seasoning but then we're
just gonna put it this side down I'm
putting a little bit more of the
marinade seasoning then more water this
is really similar to three guess a clip
dad like potatoes and carrots we call it
sauce boil a ah just literally jamon
sauce oh she's got a little dark but
it's okay I'm done - I'm so cute
the chicken it needs to sue for about 30
minutes
this is moist you know my god you taste
all the flavors you can just solve your
mo home and now I'm gonna start my rice
whoo it's arroz con gandules time
I like to use short grain rice I'm gonna
eyeball about two and a half fish cups
I'm going to turn on the stove cause we
kind of want to toast up the rice a
little bit for like optimum flavor I'm
gonna add a little bit of safflower oil
I'm gonna now add oh so good when I saw
you mixing it up I'm gonna add this very
liberally and then just mix it up some
people like a lot I'm one of those
people yeah I might actually add more
you know that
yes it's sauce on that but what is that
friends'll I had to get the sauce on in
packaging because we literally searched
far and wide for a I think I'll hand it
over to trash demon Joyce this is where
I need you oh yes may I please have chef
the tomato paste mm-hmm great so I'm
gonna use about a spoonful of that I
kind of got lost in it for a second
sorry dreaming about eating this and
IKEA telling me to come inside boom yeah
and got it this is the tomato water that
we got like to clean out the can you can
never have too many olives please
include some of the juice we haven't
added water yet we're just kind of
adding like liquid and seasonings some
people love putting in the pickled
roasted bell peppers so I'm just gonna
throw it in there especially since this
is a vegetarian one and last but not
least the star of the show the gun
doulas
also could not find in bulk oh I'm gonna
dump the whole can in with the juices
I'm gonna add some adobo seasoning in
there sometimes it doesn't eat extra
water but in this case it needs a little
bit of extra water I'm gonna set it on
high until I see it boiling and then
once it starts boiling a lot I'm gonna
cover it and then put it on low and then
let it simmer right
is like a meal by itself I love Danny I
have the pleasure of being her best
friend so I've definitely eaten them
before we're going to put the lobsters
in boiling water for literally Luria SH
seconds until they get really red and
I'm gonna put them back in cold water so
you don't want them to overcook because
I want them to really cook in the sauce
that I'm gonna make but I want it to be
easier to peel the filling we're gonna
use our sofrito you let that simmer for
a minute I'm gonna add a little bit of
adobo and I'm gonna add my lobster a
little bit of the leftover lobster water
we're gonna add sauce on well now that
we got the sauce time to mofongo frying
up the plantains
the best part I'm so excited it looks so
yummy I haven't found the pylon in LA
it's really hard to find so I'm just
using Ari's mortar and pestle half with
the garlic a little bit of oil throw a
decent-sized Chucho drone in you wanted
to get like sort of like a pasty
consistency and then I slowly throw in
the plantains and mash you smell it and
then I'm just gonna keep mashing until I
get a good consistency and that's when I
add some of this sauce from this guy not
too much because you don't want it too
saucy and then a couple more usually I'd
porn the ball with the peel and then it
kind of like slides out with like a
knife and you can kind of just plop it
in but we're just using the mortar and
pestle and that's why I'm balling it up
with my hand look at that oh it's
beautiful
so nice oh good for real yeah oh that's
what I care about
how's that Lobster Oh season
if the trooper being baked because we
didn't finish cooking until the night
but once you eat here like damn some
fire food this is a track he made this
is trash you made this is not bad
aluminum is highly recyclable you guys
both use this tomato paste there's some
produce stickers and there's also like
these herb things what you can do to
avoid that is going to the farmers
market you can get produce and herbs
package free and they won't come in
these little tags we also have some
seals for some of the spices that's kind
of unavoidable a lot of times let's you
get your spice in bulk but those weren't
at the stores we went to for all your
food scraps we can compost that so you
guys made food to serve about four to
five people Danny your zero waste
version was sixty forty four and what
you usually spend was fifty-one
eighty-six so the zero waste version
came in at eight dollars and fifty eight
cents more turbo and Joyce your zero
waste version came in at forty three
thirty one all right what you would
normally spend was 5678
so you actually spent 13 point forty
seven glass I did take out things like
olive oil and black pepper because most
people have in their kitchen
[Music]
time I think a little bit more intense
because we have to go to two stories
would you guys make these dishes again
in the zero waste way yeah
no we didn't take too much time because
we did have to go to great places I'm
gonna do this I already know I'm gonna
be wearing my heart and soul into it it
seems like you know for my heart and
soul to the environment but what about
you Hey all we do is marinate overnight
somewhere as well keep the weights down
we cooked all day yeah we cooked all day
we did it our way cuz it's the always
zero okay it's okay with zero place then
we do it our way